aus dem gesamtkomplex gerissen sind uns
gezielt beschädigen sollten die dame
habe ich einmal an diesem besagten
privaten abendessen in meinem rücken
getroffen danach nie wieder einen
kontakt zu ihr gehabt und nie wieder
gesehen keine spenden sind die partei
oder gemeinnützige vereine ergangen von
den besagten namen die genannt wurden
sind und auch niemand anderes in der
partei hat er mit dieser dame und diesem
deutschen bekannten der dame kontakt
nämlich so ein rein privates treffen
wohl nur wir beide diesen kontakt hatten
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
ich weiß genau dass ich im rahmen dieses
gespräches und das war ein abendessen
von 17 uhr bis nach mitternacht fast
sieben stunden dort verbracht habe und
im rahmen dieses gespräches immer wieder
penibel auf die einhaltung aller
gesetzlichen bestimmungen unseres
rechtsstaates bestanden habe und das
habe ich mehrmals deutlich und klar
betont und es gab und gibt bei mir keine
illegalen rechtswidrigen vorgänger auch
keine handlung an diesbezüglich und so
verlange ich natürlich auch die
herausgabe des gesamten rechtswidrig
erstellten videomaterials welche
letztlich auch belegen wird und nicht
nur die ausgewählten ausschnitt etwas
das auch genau so hat stattgefunden hat
in einem siebenstündigen privaten
gespräch in meinem urlaub würde ich ja
unter ausnutzung einer zunehmenden
alkoholisierung und ja es war eine
besoffene geschichte und ich war in
einer intimen atmosphäre verleitet auch
unreflektiert und mit lockerer zunge
über alles und jedes zu polemisieren und
ja meine äußerungen waren nüchtern
gesehen katastrophal und ausgesprochen
peinlich
ich stehe nicht an all jene um
entschuldigung zu bitten sich damit in
misskredit gebracht habe und mit meinen
unbedachten äußerungen auch gekränkt und
beleidigt habe und auch den jetzigen
bundeskanzler über den ich damals auch
um überprüfte schmutzige gerüchte auch
besprochen und gestreut hatte es war ein
typisch alkoholbedingt das machogehabe
mit dem ich ja wahrscheinlich auch die
attraktive gastgeberin beeindrucken
wollte und ich habe mich prahlerisch wie
ein teenager verhalten und peinlich
übersteigert auch agiert und damit habe
ich letztlich den wichtigsten menschen
in meinem leben so tief verletzt nämlich
meine frau und lieber verliebt ich weiß
dass du jetzt du siehst und ich kann
verstehen dass du verletzt und ein
beispiel ist und ich hoffe du kannst mir
verzeihen denn es tut mir aufrichtig
leid möchte vom ganzen herzen auch bei
dir entschuldigen
es erscheint mir aber auch wichtig zu
betonen dass mit diesem geheimen bild
und tonaufzeichnungen mehrfach straff
gesetzliche vorschriften verletzt worden
sind und dagegen verstoßen würde
genauso würde verstößen gegen den
ehrenkodex der presse und die
journalistische sorgfaltspflicht und die
berufsethik der einzige strafrechtlicher
verstoß der vorliegt ist diese
geheimdienstlich inszenierte loch falle
mit illegalen aufzeichnungen wo man zwei
jahre zu gewartet hat und diese dann in
folge auch zu zünden und ja das war ein
gezieltes politisches attentat eine
auftragsarbeit
und wer geglaubt hat dass mit
silberstein schon das niederträchtige
niveau erreicht war
wird eines schlechteren belehrt und ich
frage mich ernsthaft wozu diese
gruppierungen und netzwerke mit ihrer
kriminellen energie noch zu allem fähig
sind
ich weiß sehr genau wie man es etwas
gesetzwidriges angeboten oder gemacht zu
haben und ich werde daher auch alle
rechtlichen schritte unternehmen sowohl
mit medienrechtlichen als auch
strafrechtlichen anzeigen
wir haben einige indizien auch was
mögliche mittäter betrifft und die gegen
mich erhobenen vorwürfe mit eigenen
wieder zur verfügung stehenden mitteln
zu entkräften und gleichzeitig
diejenigen die mit wirklich kriminelle
machenschaften gegen mich vorgegangen
sind zu überführen
und ich frage mich wer diese netzwerke
sind und welche rolle auch der herr
böhme man in diesem zusammenhang spielt
aber dessen ungeachtet sage ich halte zu
mir aber auch zu ihnen ja es war dumm
es war unverantwortlich und es war ein
fehler und ich bin seit 14 jahren in
meiner verantwortung
bei obmann der freiheitlichen partei und
seitdem habe ich gemeinsam mit meinen
weggefährten und mitstreiter in einem
landesgruppe der fpö durch konsequente
und nachhaltige arbeit zu einer größe
geführt in der wir alle uns ja alle
gemeinsam auf augenhöhe mit dem
koalitionspartner unsere politischen
inhalte umsetzen und denjenigen einer
diese erfolgreiche regierungsarbeit
einfahren im auge ist möchte ich
keinesfalls auch nur irgendeinen vorwand
liefern
mein fehlverhalten als begründung zu
nehmen diese regierung zu fall zu
bringen
wenn die freiheitliche
regierungsbeteiligung bedeutet dass wir
in den ersten jahren fünf monaten wollen
verantwortung tragen mehr sicherheit
mehr geld für die pensionisten und für
die arbeitende bevölkerung und für die
familien sichergestellt haben
und auch sicherstellen eine steuerreform
keine schulden mehr
in unserem land den mitbürgern zumuten
ein strenges und konsequentes und system
aber auch wenn es in der
integrationsfrage einiges lieblose
positiven sinn zu korrigieren ist die
richtigen entscheidungen auch
sichergestellt zu haben kopftuchverbot
in den kindergärten und volksschulen
auch kampf gegen ich sage den
extremismus im allgemeinen aber auch den
politischen islam und dem antisemitismus
in unserer gesellschaft und eine
europapolitik die an österreichs
interessen orientiert ist und ja es gibt
noch viel zu tun denn wir wollen das
regierungsprogramm ja weiterhin umsetzen
und wir stehen zu diesem
regierungsprogramm in unserer gelebten
verantwortung für österreich und seine
bevölkerung und meine person darf aber
nicht der grund dafür sein dass zu
verunmöglichen und vielleicht einen
vorwand zu liefern
diese regierung zu sprechen denn das war
das ziel dieser rechtswidrig angelegten
akkordierten schmutzkübel aktion die
hier stattgefunden hat und deshalb habe
ich heute um 11 uhr ein gesprächen mit
dem herrn bundeskanzler sebastian kurz
gehabt wo ich meinen rücktritt von der
funktion des vizekanzlers der republik
österreich angeboten habe und er diese
entscheidung annehmen wird
dies tue ich in meiner verantwortung für
dieses projekt ist durch in meiner
verantwortung einen weiteren schatten
vor allen dingen auch von meiner familie
das ist das wichtigste im leben und von
meiner partei und dem amt auch
abzuwenden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ja
darüber hinaus werde ich am sonntag in
um das parteipräsidium eine übergabe als
bundesparteiobmann sicherstellen und
meine obmann funktion auch zurücklegen
werden wollte auch die weiteren gremien
auch in der landespartei einberufen und
die entsprechenden schritte setzen und
die führung der partei an gelegen hatten
wir ab sofort mein stellvertreter
norbert hofer auch übernehmen und
abschließend möchte ich mich aufrichtig
entschuldigen die ich in meinem
verhalten enttäuscht habe meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren denn natürlich
und das möchte ich auch gleichzeitig
betonen möchte ich mich bei all meinen
jahrelangen dreien unterstützung wählern
natürlich auch der mitarbeitern in der
partei auch im ministerium für ihre
arbeit für ihren einsatz für ihre
loyalität und ihren arbeitseinsatz
danken und gerade in dieser schweren
stunde bitte ich bei den vielen bürgern
und verständnis die mir gestern in
unzähligen telefonaten mails postings
den rücken gestärkt haben und mir
rückhalt gegeben haben dieser gedanke
und wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag
wow das war mal ein donnerschlag aus
wien ich begrüße ganz herzlich bei mir
im studio professor tim meyer
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität hier in bonn schön dass sie
so schnell zu uns geeilt sind
das ist ein paukenschlag es bleiben aber
fragen offen befassen erst mal zusammen
er tritt zurück als vizekanzler er tritt
zurück als parteiobmann also
vorsitzender
aber es ist nicht die rede davon dass
die koalition platzt ist das aus seiner
warte jetzt wie haben sie das jetzt
wahrgenommen den auftritt von heinz
christian strache
na gut er war schon der situation
angemessen ehrlich und selbst anklagend
also es blieb eigentlich nichts übrig
was man eben noch weiter hätte vorwerfen
müssen natürlich versucht er sich frei
zu schaufeln und zusagen rechtlich wenn
er alle register ziehen aber er ist
natürlich absolut in der defensive er
versucht seine irgendwie hat man den
eindruck in der regierung zu halten
durch sein rücktritt also nicht zu
beschädigen das zu versuchen
aber natürlich liegt es an bundeskanzler
kurz jetzt darüber zu befinden ob er
dieses manöver weiter fortsetzen will
oder ob er die reißleine zieht und dafür
sprechen natürlich ein paar gründe
weltfrieden sofort weiter ich sagt
unseren zuschauern natürlich nur dass
wir noch nicht genau wissen wann und ob
sebastian kurz sich äußern wird ist es
sicher so abgesprochen gewesen dass
zunächst der vizekanzler
dort auftreten wird ist kann sein dass
jetzt einfach nur sozusagen die hintere
wand auf der stand ja vizekanzler
geändert wird und dann der bundeskanzler
gegebenenfalls dort an gleicher stätte
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt eine
pressekonferenz ein wird dagegen spricht
allerdings dass ich das sehen sie jetzt
nicht gerade über den monitor sehen kann
dass dort alle mikrofone abgebaut werden
also man muss jetzt einfach mal abwarten
wie es dort in wien weiter geht wird der
bundeskanzler sich äußern sehen sie das
selbstverständlich auch live bei uns
also kommen wir noch mal zu diesem punkt
wie geht es weiter mit der koalition
also es scheint ja offensichtlich zu
sein
das vielleicht noch keine entscheidung
gefallen ist oder die absprache ist dass
es natürlich den bundeskanzler so wie
sie es gerade jetzt skizziert haben
vorbehalten ist diese entscheidung dann
möglicherweise bekannt zu geben genau ja
muss das heft in der hand haben wir
haben die europawahlen vor uns und er
muss natürlich da eine entsprechenden
auftritt hinlegen
die erwartungen sind wahrscheinlich doch
international gesehen sehr groß dass er
hier einen schnitt macht und auch muss
man sagen die chance nutzt seine vp
entsprechend gut dastehen zu lassen denn
es ist ja seinem geschick zu verdanken
dass er überhaupt so dasteht wie er da
steht die svp war mal unterhalb des der
anerkennungs schwelle von der fpö
gelegen und er hat sozusagen
herumgerissen das oder durch auch
gewisse zugeständnisse in das mehr
rechte lager aber jedenfalls ist sie ihm
gelungen
im unterschied zum beispiel zu italien
oder anderen ländern dass er die nummer
1 ist und mit seiner svp das heft in der
hand hat und sofern diese koalition
eingehen aber als der macher und diese
funktion wird es sich wahrscheinlich
nicht nehmen lassen wollen und insofern
könnte man natürlich sagen es ist ein
sich eine gewisse steilvorlage für ihn
jetzt zu agieren als derjenige der
integer die dinge bereinigt und
bereinigen muss und dass man eben das
auch entsprechend zugute hält dass er so
agieren muss aber wir wissen es
natürlich noch nicht also sprechen von
diesem moment tun was er jetzt hat er
würde es sicherlich eine nicht
unerhebliche zahl an fv wlan entweder
von der wahl ohne fernhalten
beispielsweise jetzt bei der
bevorstehenden europawahl oder noch
einen sehr großen teil zur vp
rüberziehen können die ursprünglich ja
mal anders die seiten gewechselt haben
sowohl von der svp als auch von der spd
müsste dann aber die europawahl wird
sicherlich schon die auswirkungen dieses
heutigen tages spüren was sie zieren sie
die bisher stabil nur millimeter hinter
der spd gelandet wenn ich das richtig in
erinnerung habe weil der wahl was
glauben sie wird das jetzt für ein
erdbeben an der wahl ohne erzeugen
nächste woche es ist natürlich nicht so
ganz abzuschätzen je nachdem wie auch
international dieser fall beachtet wird
wir haben ja
sehen ein unwahrscheinliches
medieninteresse ich glaube ich habe
gehört über 200 journalisten waren
allein bei dem rücktritt jetzt oder
diese ankündigung dabei das heißt also
immense aufregung die eben einfach nur
international zu erklären ist vor dem
hintergrund der europawahlen und von
daher kann natürlich durchaus eine
kleine beschädigung dieser formation des
rechten lagers passieren und will man
natürlich von dort aus schaden abnehmen
aber das wird natürlich wie möglich sein
das heißt also ich glaube schon das ist
ein gewissen auftrieb für vp und
vielleicht auch sein dürfen
das wäre jetzt die interessante frage
die sich unmittelbar anschließt wir
blicken auf die europawahl die ja schon
in einigen ländern am kommenden
donnerstag beginnt wird dass sie haben
das medieninteresse angesprochen wird
dass möglicherweise tatsächlich
ausschlag auch geben können für die
abstimmung in anderen ländern was
beispielsweise rechtspopulistische
parteien angeht oder halten sie das
tatsächlich für er eine österreichische
geschichte also insgesamt ist es
natürlich zunächst mal eine
österreichische geschichte aber es kommt
natürlich ein auge auf ein gewisser sub
song das hier irgendwie etwas in diesem
lager nicht so ganz koscher ist und das
färbt ab und ist natürlich zumindest ein
erschwernis für die ganzen formation
salvini und le pen und auch afd und
sofern muss man das schon gewärtigen
interessanterweise treffen sich genau
heute marie le pen und es sei wenig
unterhalten wird zu einem großen treffen
der rechtspopulisten erwartet das wird
er sich auch dem thema sein das soll
nämlich auch quasi jetzt in diesen
stunden passieren wir haben man wird
sich natürlich jetzt dann von strache
und seinen taten distanzieren wollen und
auch irgendwie können
aber wie sie sagen es bleibt einfach und
proben kam es ja auch zu diesem
rücktritt
es wird da was hängen bleiben und
von daher ist natürlich für dieses lager
jetzt sind ist da ein brocken auf den
weg gerollt worden
den zu überwinden innerhalb der kurzen
zeit von der vom ansehen her sicherlich
sehr schwer sein dürfte
blicken wir auf die bringen wir mal auf
die möglichkeit das aus was für gründen
auch immer die koalition tatsächlich
bestehen bliebe sebastian kurz
entscheidet sich für eine fortsetzung
norbert hofer wäre der neue starke mann
unser korrespondent michael mandt liegt
hat gesagt dass er als moderator ein
modell des moderators oder moderator
gilt und ja auch nur sehr knapp die
präsidentschaftswahlen verloren hat in
österreich was würde das in der politik
möglicherweise verhindern
ja also wie gesagt aus unter- oder gäbe
es überhaupt gründe warum kurz die
koalition fortsetzen oder eben also es
gibt gerade bei diesem wechsel jetzt
einmal parteipolitisch gedacht als vp
sicht gibt es natürlich eigentlich kein
grund mit hofer jemand zu installieren
der ein gewisses ansehen hatte sie haben
erwähnt die die bundespräsidentenwahl wo
er knapp verloren hat insofern ist
sofort wie hatte gar keinen kandidaten
doch doch das hat ja zuerst aber
insofern ist es also aus taktischen
gründen für ihn natürlich besser wenn er
dass die die sache beendet
andererseits kann es vielleicht eher
einen grund geben dass er sagt wir
müssen das doch fortsetzen und zu ende
führen oder solche für seine philosophie
entwickeln die wir jetzt noch nicht so
parat haben
es wäre jedenfalls ein schweres eine
schwere belastung dieses bündnis diesen
schritt zu setzen das wäre wenn man den
werdegang sebastian kurz als ich ein
bisschen vor augen führt er ist ja
wirklich instinktpolitiker anhalt trotz
seines jungen alters schon als
außenminister gepunktet was ihnen ja
überhaupt erst in die position gebracht
hat die svp zu übernehmen und dort jetzt
auch als kanzler die republik österreich
zu führen da spreche doch sicherlich
wenn man in diesen instinkt immer noch
zutraut vieles dafür dass er sagt jetzt
ist der moment und besser kann es ja
eigentlich
ich kann mir jetzt jedenfalls einfach
noch nicht vorstellen hat dass er die
kontinuität vorzieht
jetzt natürlich ist es spektakulär diese
ganze geschichte und auch dann ein
schlussstrich zu machen die koalition
auf zu können ist natürlich auch ein
harter schnitt auch für ihn weil er
nicht weiß wie die dinge sich weiter
entwickeln durch zustimmung in der
bevölkerung usw
die spd wird sehr stark dagegen schießen
aber ich kann mir noch nicht vorstellen
wie die an eine kontinuität dieser
regierung begründet werden kann auch
moralisch sozusagen und von daher glaube
ich spricht viel dafür dass hier auch
weiterhin spektakuläre nachrichten aus
österreich kommen ja es bleibt ja noch
spannend weil wir immer noch nicht
wissen wie es weitergeht wir haben es ja
auch schon besprochen und blicken
nämlich mal auf genau das was passiert
ist und bringen unsere zuschauer noch
einmal auf den aktuellen stand vor
wenigen minuten gegen die
pressekonferenz von heinz christian
strache dem noch vize kanzler der
republik österreich zu ende er hat
seinen rücktritt angekündigt angeboten
hat auch gesagt der bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz wird diesen annehmen er
wird auch seinen posten als parteiobmann
also zu deutsch vor parteivorsitzender
abgeben das an norbert hofer es ist aber
nicht klar geworden in der
pressekonferenz dass wie es jetzt
weitergeht mit der koalition deswegen
warten wir